der sächsische cdu ministerpräsident
kretschmann dürfte gerade ein mittleres
politisches erdbeben in der union
ausgelöst haben hier sehen wir ihn in
moskau bei einem telefonat mit putin vor
einem jahr entgegen der linie seiner
partei hat er sich der forderung von
knapp 30 prominenten rund um die
feministin alice schwarzer angeschlossen
die sich in einem brief an bundeskanzler
olaf scholz gegen waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine aussprechen ihre sorge das
heißt den krieg weiter an und bringt
auch uns in deutschland in gefahr alice
schwarzer wie gesagt aber auch reinhard
mey der schauspieler lars eidinger und
andere sind die unterzeichnungen die
reaktionen darauf in der öffentlichkeit
im wesentlichen
unverständnis und ablehnung und jetzt
kommt also kretschmann einer der
führenden cdu politiker und hat nach
bild -informationen heute in der
gemeinsamen präsidiumssitzung von cdu
und csu folgendes gesagt der offene
brief an den kanzler bildet nicht die
mehrheit der veröffentlichten meinung ab
aber durchaus mehrheitsmeinung der
gesellschaft auch meine diese position
muss auch von der union berücksichtigt
werden es gibt allen grund diesem land
zu helfen auch mit waffen es geht aber
darum einen waffenstillstand zu
erzwingen russland wird auch danach eine
realität seien sanktionen treffen uns
zum großen teil selbst das also nachdem
gerade die union massiv auf
waffenlieferungen gedrängt hatte den
kanzler damit in zugzwang brachte und
das bevor cdu-chef märz jetzt nach kiew
reisen will der reagierte auf
kretzschmar dementsprechend schmallippig
mit den worten wir reden hier offen es
gibt verschiedene meinungen ich habe
eine andere gehen wir in die ukraine zu
paul ronzheimer paul einer der führenden
cdu politiker spricht sich gegen den
kurs seiner partei aus und dass er
unmittelbar bevor merz in die ukraine
reist welche signale sendet das an die
ukraine
thomas ist ein einzigartiger form nicht
nur gegenüber der ukraine sondern auch
gegenüber friedrich merz du hast es
angesprochen in den stunden in denen
sich friedrich merz der
parteivorsitzende der cdu der mehr
waffen wollte der schneller
waffenlieferung wollte in diesen stunden
in den zug nach hier sitzt macht nicht
irgendjemand diese aussagen sondern
michael kretschmer einer der mächtigsten
ministerpräsidenten der union einer der
mächtigsten politiker der union denn es
gibt ja keine minister mehr weil man im
bund in der opposition ist und natürlich
der mächtigste cdu mann im osten und das
setzt friedrich merz vor dem besuch hier
in der ukraine massiv unter druck das
wird hier natürlich thema werden und das
schmälert natürlich seine chancen auch
den ukrainischen präsidenten vlotho
meese lenski zu treffen denn dass
ausgerechnet kretschmer das gesagt hat
das wird hier schockwellen auslösen mann
ist von kretschmer eine nähe zu wladimir
putin gewöhnt man hat gesehen wie er
dorthin gefahren ist in den vergangenen
jahren immer wieder dafür auch geworben
hat die sanktionen aufzulösen aber
thomas das war vor dem 24 februar dass
er sich jetzt hinstellt und sich diesem
manifest muss man ja fast sagen der
vermeintlich intellektuellen in
deutschland anschließt bedeutet ja auch
dass das ganze thema jetzt politisch
wird das ist brisant wird und dass das
ein erdbeben in der union auslösen
werden nun ist die meinung in der
gesellschaft nach jüngsten umfragen paul
hier in deutschland allerdings durchaus
gespalten fifty fifty kann man sagen pro
und contra
waffenlieferungen hat kretschmer da sein
ohr näher an der basis als friedrich
merz
also erstmal muss man sagen dass diese
zahlen sich verändert haben es gibt
mittlerweile eine große mehrheit für
waffenlieferungen das ist nicht mehr so
wie es vor dem krieg oder zu beginn des
krieges war und es ist eben ein problem
wenn die union die traditionell mehr und
enger an der seite der usa steht sich
davon entfernt das heißt friedrich merz
wird jetzt ein machtwort sprechen müssen
er wird wahrscheinlich in den offenen
konflikt mit michael kretschmer gehen
müssen am ende muss man davon ausgehen
dass kretschmer da ausschließlich auf
wahltaktische gründe
gespielt und selbst wenn wir wissen alle
dass in ostdeutschland
die nähe zu russland noch viel stärker
ausgeprägt ist als in an an teilen des
landes allerdings thomas es ist ja nicht
irgendein offener brief sondern ein
offener brief der massiv kritisiert
wurde vor allem nicht weil man gesagt
hat keine schweren waffen ich glaube
wenn man das begründen würde dann wäre
das eine debatte in der gesellschaft und
diese debatte gibt es ja natürlich und
das ist auch gut so nein man hat einfach
in diesem offenen brief geschrieben ist
soll jetzt friedensverhandlungen geben
ja aber was bedeutet das im
umkehrschluss dass die ukraine aufgeben
soll das impliziert das was diejenigen
dort unterschrieben haben denn es gebe
keine andere lösung weil die mir putin
nicht bereit ist seine truppen aus dem
land zu ziehen und das ist ja dann am
ende das auch was michael kretschmer
unterstützt wenn er diesen offenen brief
unterstützt er wendet sich nicht nur
gegen die lieferung schwerer waffen
sondern im umkehrschluss sagt er auch
die ukraine soll aufgeben und das thomas
ist in der jetzigen lage eine absolute
bombe für die union lassen
sagte friedrich merz wird sich in den
zug setzen und in die ukraine fahren
auch gregor gysi will in die ukraine
kommen es findet ja inzwischen sozusagen
ein regelrechter polit tourismus in die
ukraine statt und die frage ist eben es
etwas was der ukraine hilft oder ist das
etwas das den politikern helfen sollen
bevor wir weiterreden schauen wir uns
mal kurz an wer schon alles da war
friedrich merz und gregor gysi packen
die koffer auf in die ukraine heißt es
nun auch für die kleinste und die größte
deutsche oppositionspartei von morgen
bis sonntag will linken politiker die
sie durch die ukraine reisen märz macht
sich noch heute nacht nach kiew auf die
frage ist ob solche reisen der ukraine
etwas nützen oder nur den reisenden
selbst viele haben es ihnen vorgemacht
als erstes reisten die regierungschefs
von polen tschechien und slowenien ins
kriegsgebiet es folgten ursula von der
leyen angelina jolie boris johnson
us-außenminister anthony blinken und
us-verteidigungsminister lloyd austin
natürlich durfte auch die sprecherin des
us repräsentantenhauses nancy pelosi
nicht fehlen die jetzt gerade dort ist
am liebsten sind den ukrainer natürlich
besuch die konkrete hilfe mitbringen
wirtschaftlich humanitär militärisch
präsident selensky stellt klar dass er
waffen braucht wir brauchen schwere
waffen um eine chance zu haben darauf
müssen wir zählen kann gemeinsam können
wir es schaffen den russischen
belagerungsring zu durchbrechen bis
jetzt haben wir von diesen waffen nicht
genug um dieses ziel erreichen zu können
und aus deutschland bisher reiste ein
ampel gespann aus fdp frau marie agnes
strack zimmermann dem grünen ex
pazifisten toni hofreiter und michael
roth von der spd nach kiew nur olaf
scholz der der wirklich etwas bewegen
konnte war noch nicht da sind die
ukraine inzwischen auch ein bisschen
genervt von besuchern die nicht im
gepäck haben außer einer kamera
vielleicht um sich mit selen ski
fotografieren zu lassen
[Musik]
dass die ukraine genervt sind von
besuchern vor allem denjenigen die
besonders russland nahe position
vertreten haben thomas das haben wir
eine ausladung von frank walter
steinmeier den bundespräsidenten gesehen
dass jetzt gregor gysi kommt ich glaube
darüber freut sich hier niemand der nun
wirklich eine ja sehr sehr intensive
beziehung nach moskau und nach russland
gepflegt hat aber man kann es ja auch
niemandem verbieten man gar nicht sagen
man ist das land der freiheit der
demokratie und dann macht man die grenze
zur krise also man kann sich auch nicht
so richtig dagegen wehren was jetzt für
dich märz an geht das wird spannend zu
sehen seien noch einmal ob er denn
tatsächlich den präsidenten treffen wird
meiner kenntnis nach zuletzt meinen
informationen von heute morgen war es so
dass es für morgen noch keinen festen
termin zwischen selensky und märz gibt
also möglicherweise bekommt märz gar
keinen termin und das wäre dann schon
wieder ein bisschen peinlich
sie fahren also nach kiew märz wird ihr
für paul du bist direkt an der
frontlinie da wo die russischen angriffe
im momente stattfinden und du bist heute
mit ukrainischen soldaten unterwegs
gewesen wir schauen uns mal die bilder
an die du uns geschickt hast bevor wir
weiter sprechen
der donbass im osten der ukraine drohen
aufnahmen die die aktuelle frontlinie
zeigen sollen in unmittelbarer nähe bild
vize paul ronzheimer
hier gab es vor 30 minuten einschläge so
sieht die donners front aus und wir
haben im hintergrund dort wo der rauch
zu sehen ist die frontlinie hier im
donbass die umkämpfte front linie aber
es ist mittlerweile mehr ein krieg der
artillerie denn der verschieden gewehre
und deswegen feuern ukrainer und russen
in unterschiedlichen zeiträumen hier
aufeinander aber die ukraine sagen uns
wir haben nicht genug munition momentan
um auf die russischen angriffe zu
antworten
ganz in der nähe trifft paul auf eine
ukrainische militäreinheit die an
vorderster front kämpft wie würdest du
die aktuelle russische offensive
beschreiben
ich würde sagen sie ist stabil
artillerie beschuss von morgens bis
abends
es gibt kaum zeiten in denen sie nicht
schießen
bei regen oder bei starken wind oder bei
nacht wenn es schwierig ist die schüsse
zu korrigieren sind die einzigen zeiten
in der sie uns nicht beschließen
um die russischen stellungen beobachten
zu können verwenden die ukraine immer
öfter drohnen wozu genau werden die
drohnen eingesetzt und wie wichtig sind
sie im krieg hier im donbass die
aufklärung aus der luft ist immens
wichtig fast alle unsere militärischen
erfolge basieren auf der aufklärung aus
der luft
und wie funktionieren diese drohen hier
sind kleine kameras und mit denen ihr
die position der außen beobachtet
richtig ja wir beobachten damit die
stellung der russen zu sowjetzeiten
mussten wir uns an schleichen um an
infos zu kommen heute können wir eine
drohne schicken
wir haben die drohne
es sind ganz gewöhnliche chinesische
drohende die wir nun leicht umgebaut
haben es sind die neuesten modelle aber
jeder kann sie ganz normal kaufen
die tatsächliche frontlinie ist nur
wenige kilometer entfernt
jetzt sehen wir die zerstörung der stadt
das ist marie kann richtig ja das ist
marica wir sind nur wenige kilometer weg
kann man den feind sehen nein erst wenn
wir darüber fliegen sind das die drohen
die den kriegsverlauf entscheiden werden
wir haben sich im gespräch gesehen mit
dem ukrainischen soldaten dort der ja
wie soll ich sagen ganz nüchtern wirkte
und die sache dort analysiert hat ist
das dein eindruck auch dort was die
soldaten er geradezu professionell
inzwischen umgehen mit dieser situation
also gerade diese einheit thomas die ich
dort getroffen habe der kommandeur ist
verantwortlich für uns 600 soldaten da
lebte wirklich sehr konzentriert und
sehr fokussiert darauf aber auch sehr
realistisch er hat gesagt am ende haben
die russen noch die besseren waffen sie
haben noch mehr munition als wir aber
trotzdem haben sie noch es nicht
geschafft uns überrennen also es ist ein
täglicher kampf und auch als wir dort
waren gab es beschuss das den rauch dort
im video sehen können und in einem
moment mussten wir dann schleunigst weg
denn es kam eine feindliche drohnen und
teilweise sind in diesen drohen die
rauchbomben eingebaut mit denen dann die
ukraine attackiert werden also da ist
ein ständiger beschuss im donbass nur
gleichzeitig muss man sehen dass die
russen nicht so viel land gewinnen wie
sie wollten nicht so viel land gewinnen
vor allem wie sie bis zum 9 mai also bis
zum tag der kapitulation
nazideutschlands gewinnen wollen vor
diesem hintergrund die frage paul es
gibt befürchtungen dass russland auch
als nächstes gebiete in der republik
moldau angreifen könnte also im westen
der ukraine du bist dort im osten jetzt
immer don was haben die russen überhaupt
die kraft sozusagen eine weitere front
zu eröffnen
das ginge nur wenn dort eben aus moldau
soldaten sich beteiligten diese
spekulationen gibt es immer wieder dass
man versucht dort kämpfer soldaten
anzuwerben um eine weitere front in
richtung und jetzt eben aufzumachen
tatsache ist thomas russland braucht
dringend mehr soldaten wenn man hier
vorankommen will sie brauchen auch
weitere waffen sie müssen wahrscheinlich
noch einmal eine umgruppierung vornehmen
um hier wirklich erfolg zu haben denn
noch einmal man hat zwar einzelne halb
große städte nenne ich es mal die hessen
zum beispiel 300.000 einwohner relativ
am anfang des krieges erobern können
aber aktiv ist nicht in russischer hand
nur düster ist nicht den russischen kiew
sowieso nicht also die großen städte
sage ich mal das was man in ostern sehen
wollte die sind weiterhin ukrainische
hand und die frage ist wird putin
versuchen dort irgendwie raus zu kommen
und trotzdem zu sagen riesensieg wir
haben die ukraine zitiert wir haben
mario pohl besetzt und so weiter oder
wird er nach dem neunten mal versuchen
eine generalmobilmachung
vorzunehmen und dann weitere rekruten
her zu bringen bei putin ist wie immer
alles möglich und im zweifel sollten wir
vom schlimmsten fall ausgehen also einem
langen langen dramatischen krieg in der
tat bis zum neunten mal sind es nur noch
sieben tage bis dahin wird nicht mehr
viel zu erreichen seien
absolut da wird man keine großstadt
zumindest mehr erreichen können man wird
auch keine stadt in dem sinne erreichen
können slavia immer wieder in der
diskussion das ist ein ort der ja sehr
symbolisch hier ist weil 2014 ist der
erste ort war den separatisten damals
zusammen mit russischen soldaten nach
dem majdan erobert hatten von dort aus
ging damals der krieg aus also ein
symbolträchtiger ort und man war davon
ausgegangen dass putin den in jedem fall
besetzen will bis zum 9 also in sieben
tagen thomas ich sehe das nicht und
deswegen müssen wir davon ausgehen dass
es nach dem 9 wahrscheinlich noch
heftiger wird paul ronzheimer ganz
herzlichen dank paul